hello everyone
welcome back to the collider youtube
channel we've got another south by
southwest 2021 interview with justine
bateman here with her movie
violet justine congratulations first
feature as a writer director and that is
just a huge accomplishment
thank you yeah um i'm thrilled with uh
how it turned out i'm thrilled with the
response it's gotten very happy
you definitely should be just in case
our viewers do not know what violet is
about though just yet
would you mind giving a brief synopsis
generally speaking it's about
the thoughts we have or in the in the
film i call it the voice
um that treats us like crap that makes
us make fear-based decisions the example
i give is
um the the thought a voice that tells
you don't wear that shirt to the party
or no one's gonna talk to you
so cautiously or unconsciously you'll
change your shirt because you're afraid
that's true
so then you have uh the more times you
do that the more times you make
fear-based decisions
um the further away you get from being
your true self so this is about a woman
who realizes that that voice has been
lying to her whole life
and so she starts going against it and
then it comes at her harder and
just like how do you get from a life
that's
uh made of fear-based decisions to a
life that's made of instinct-based
decisions
that was a very good synopsis but i feel
the need to tell everybody out there
that just
hearing that does not do the movie
justice because
your style with bringing that kind of
concept to life on screen is
is some really unique next level stuff
and olivia is just
something else in this movie i don't
think i've ever seen a performance quite
like that from her yet so it was very
exciting to see how you kind of
pushed the range of her work at least as
much of her filmography as i've seen
yeah i mean when i was acting you know i
certainly
remember you know you there's only so
much you can do with uh
the types of roles you get and so it
takes getting this type of role to be
able to
show what you can do so i hope she gets
many more types of roles like this
because she
really gave herself to the role and and
to the process and uh
and people are just going nuts over her
performance which is great
i'm happy to hear that going back to
last year's festival because i know how
sensitive i got when south by was
cancelled despite the
necessity of actually canceling an
in-person festival so
what was that experience like for you
and how do you kind of
you know keep yourself focused and keep
yourself forging forward
when the rug is pulled out from under
you in that sense
yeah i think what was so hard about that
cancellation versus the cancellation of
you know all the other festivals that
uh that occurred last that were supposed
to occur last year or that did in some
form
um was that it was set like it was
everything was done it was ready to go
uh all the
all the arrangements have been made all
the promotional
items you know the filmmakers had their
stuff together you know for for you guys
for the press for the
the the tech aspect of it the music
aspect of it venues have been booked i
mean as
everything was booked it would it's like
50 50 huge weddings had been
ready to go and then we couldn't do it
so and then the build-up of course to
you know
raising the money and then making the
film and getting it through post and
everything and then find you wait
you know you hear about that you're in
the festival and then you have to wait
to tell anyone and then
also all that waiting but you know
there's going to be a release
and then there's not one so i wound up
um
i i know this would sound like a humble
bread but it was really just a coping
mechanism i wound up writing four
scripts during the shutdown because i
just didn't want to be in this reality
i was like i don't want to be in
california in
2020 just i'd rather be in this
situation i'm making up
every day that's all i want to think
about is this
pretend parallel universe i
i am impressed that you were able to
channel that into something productive
like that i hope we get to see some of
those scripts too
kind of a good thing in this situation
but i was reading that you wound up
getting offers from
other festivals happening between then
and now
so why not take one of those why stay
dedicated to premiering your movie at
south by southwest in particular
i thought 2021 was definitely going to
be in person so
i uh yeah and i knew south by was going
to do theirs virtually
for this go around um but
i applied nonetheless just in case they
did it in person and you know and
applied to a couple of
you know reapplied to a couple of other
the festivals that wanted this last year
and um and then around uh november
december
like we found out about south by 2021
and also i realized that because
movie theaters were so unfairly
demonized i thought like
about you know where you're going to
catch the virus you know
cruise ships fine when actually like
tons of infections came out of cruise
ships
but movie theaters where i don't
remember hearing one case coming out of
movie theater they were vilified which i
thought was
really unfair anyway i was like oh man i
don't think we're going to have
in-person festivals in 2021 at least
not i was trying to hedge my butt so i
was like you know what this is kind of
perfect
you know i really really felt for south
by that they had to cancel for all
you know but especially for the festival
um organizers
um and they've been so supportive and so
it was kind of great to
you know just say you know let's just go
for it and the timing for me was really
great because
um all those other opportunities we
still had people
very focused on on the virus and we had
the u.s election that people were very
focused on and i thought you know what
are we going to do it's like
oh 5 000 people died today and they go
like hey everybody don't forget to catch
my film at southpaw you know i mean was
that what i was going to do
you know on social media so no i didn't
want to do that um so this has
worked out long answered your question
but this worked out really great
for for what it's worth i feel like i
needed this kind of uh
you know on-screen exploration of the
internal struggle that i deal with
now more than ever maybe so i'm kind of
glad that it's coming out
right now because now i feel like i got
a little added momentum when we get back
out into the world
that's great that's ideal so i'm glad
that that that
aspect of the timing is is on on the
mark too
i mean it all right going back to the
beginning of
the genesis of the idea i guess correct
me if i'm wrong but i think i read that
you
first got this idea in 2011 so
what were you picturing for the film at
that point and what would you say is the
biggest difference between
that version of the film and what we see
in the final version today
that's a good question i don't know that
i i mean i envisioned that it would
shoot in los angeles and i definitely
got my wish
um but i don't know i mean i was just
uh i was just at a point i was just like
writing
and then saving them just writing the
script you know i have a bunch of them
so
just like writing the scripts and saving
them not really knowing
i didn't really know at that point i'd
wanted to direct since i was 19 but
the timing never felt right i knew if i
had tried to force it to happen i would
have just kind of made a pile of junk
like that's what it is for me creatively
i have to wait for the timing
um so i didn't even know that i
was gonna wind up directing it i don't
know what was i don't know just writing
the scripts and
and putting them in a bag kind of and
just uh carrying on
i don't know do you remember the uh the
morning you woke up and said
this is it and i'm gonna direct it
um i remember thinking um
i'll give you the truncated version i
knew i wanted to do some
i have other ideas for films that are
that deal with um
with tech more specifically that i
called layered
projects but i thought okay because i i
got a
computer science degree from ucla like
not too long ago
so i i thought you know but i want to do
these more
traditionally um uh fashioned
uh shorts and films first because i know
i'll
i may not want to go back once i've
started those more complex projects
whatever this is my idea about you know
i'll never want to go back
you know whatever so i did the two
shorts
and then and i was like okay well i want
to do this feature and i know it's
i i don't want that in uh this of this
tech layered format that i
that i was have been thinking about so i
was like i'll better shoot that one too
and then you know when i started the
shorts i thought well this is this is
very smart actually because i do the
shorts
and these are examples of my writing
direct and producing and people can be
assured that
hopefully and it worked uh that they
should give me the money for the for the
film
and then i thought all right if i can
get a good financial track record with
this film
and i get money from the next film then
i can
take those successes and then show them
the more complex
proposal for the you know the tech and
entertainment combination pieces that i
want to do
you know so it's good you know like
build a good track record in
in a in in a style that people are more
familiar with
and then maybe they'll feel comfortable
giving me money for the more complex
stuff
so hope maybe it'll work out that way
that's the plan
not to deviate too much but now just
because i'm curious when you say a more
tech based approach to film do you mean
infusing uh technology and those types
of themes in your stories or
using technology in a new way to find a
different way to tell stories on screen
yeah the latter there's so much in
ar and in the touch screen technology
that
uh that i'm like i can't wait to use so
touch screen technology obviously been
around for a while
ar is still developing
towards um the way in which i want to
use it
um you know places like magic leap are
doing really exciting things and
um so i have i have high hopes for that
but yeah basically
because we have these methods available
to us through the touch screen in ar
you can change the script and i mean in
the same way
you know when you write a script you
know years ago you were script for play
and then film came on the screen i came
on the scene rather and literally on the
screen
you could change the way the script was
structured that play was structured
to take advantage of the technical
freedoms you had with the film
you know close-ups in different
locations and and you know there's all
kinds of things you could do
same thing with a tv series you could
stretch it out you it changed the stress
so
every time we have a step forward in
technology it changes the opportunities
we have for this script structure
so what we're doing for film and tv we
have to do it on a red story in a linear
manner right
but when you do something with using the
touch screen or with the ar i can write
a script that's more like a tree
because i can do deep dives into all
these different
arenas and not choose your own adventure
but basically the story is this big
so instead of structuring it like this i
can structure it like that
so in those ways and and not just doing
it for the hell of it
you know not just using those structures
for the hat for the hell of it but
rather taking stories that that need to
be told that way
you know using it to make that story
richer you know not just taking that
format and applying it to any
idea you've got it has to be an idea
that needs that kind of structure you
know anyway
you can tell i get very excited about i
can talk forever about
about all the different ways that you
know hopefully i'll have an opportunity
to use it
you're lucky i liked this movie so much
otherwise i wouldn't be able to pry
myself away from that conversation right
now
going back to violet though of all the
directors you yourself have worked with
as an actor in the past do you find
anyone's method or process
influencing your own now that you're
directing your own features the most
um well that's an interesting question
i think the method that influenced me
the most
bar none and it's not from a director
but from gary david goldberg who created
family ties
the series i was on from 16 to 21
because that was my third job in four
months like i didn't
i was like sure i'll give it a whirl and
you know
whatever wound up on a on a really
popular show
but he created that show he created that
set
he hired all those people so because of
the um
because he was so classy and talented
and even keeled so was everyone else
because he picked them
and i've been on set since of course
where
that wasn't the case and they always
seemed very unusual to me
like to me that to me having
an even keel set where if someone's got
a great idea
and it and it drives our our thesis
statement of that scene or the film
deeper we're going to use it um
and you know and respecting each other
and uh and having a good
goddamn time you know so that to me
is normal all the rest of it to me
is abnormal so that's the kind of set
i like to be on that's kind of set i
like to have and
hopefully we'll always have um but
that's what the set of violet was like
and
and so it was like it was just uh
it was fun and it was um
we got the job done i mean you know just
a bunch of like
can do people and uh
and no drama you know it was just
great and i i think that's entirely
possible depending on
who's at the top of this hiring pyramid
you know what i mean like if i
hire um department heads
that are well suited and kind of
have the same work ethic as me i totally
trust that people they hire are going to
be
like them too so you start it's the it's
a good pyramid scheme you know what i
mean
i like the sound of that going back to
olivia specifically now
when you were casting the role of violet
what was it about
her or her past work that made you say
this is someone
that could bring to life all of these
internal things because i don't know
that's just
one of the most challenging things in uh
in acting from my limited perspective is
when you're able to express
things without actually saying them
which is essentially like
it is your movie yeah right um
well you know uh like you said earlier
you know olivia hadn't
had this type of part before
um but there was something in all the
work that i saw of hers and although i
got you know not just
for the purposes of casting this phone
but you know i've been watching her for
years and
there was always like these qualities
that she had in her work
that were like glimmers and i was like
oh there
there there and i thought okay i know
like if i bring her in and then just
like
tease those those elements out and
expand them
i don't know for me casting is pretty
simple like there's a quality i need for
that character and i don't need an actor
to have played that
character before but if i see elements
of that character in what they do
while they're not even paying attention
you know i know
if they'll allow me i can go in and sort
of
harness that that small element and
expand it
um but i'll tell you something
that's interesting just as a by the way
there were a number of people that i
thought that of but um
their representatives refused to let
them meet me
they're like give me an offer and i'm
like well
it's like i've seen your guy play a
cowboy and a murderous preacher
but i haven't seen him play this type of
thing and i see elements i think would
be good but i'm gonna have to
meet them i don't need to audition them
but i'm gonna have to like
meet them to see and they're like no and
i go
all right does something like
that happen because of the size of the
film
i don't know but i just
i don't know why i just say that to say
if you're an actor out there and you
want to work with interesting people
don't let your representatives make
meeting you
impossible i don't know why i need to
say that right now but
if that's the situation it sounds like
solid advice right there
yeah because it winds up being a shame
you know
like you don't get to who knows maybe
you're gonna hit it off with that
filmmaker and then
and be in a cool film i don't know
that's very true
again going back to all your acting
experience when you're casting your own
movies
is there anything that you experienced
in the past that is specifically making
you look for something
i get i guess specific again in your
actors just in terms of
uh the collaborative nature not
necessarily what best suits the role but
a way that you
really like to work back then that now
you want to see in the people that you
are casting for you to work with as a
director
oh yeah no i got there eventually i have
very
i'll tell you what up to when i started
directing
i had assumed that all the other actors
worked the same way i did
where you you get your lines down or as
best you can sometimes you know
uh on the day you're with your tiny
script and you're like you know
you've got it and then you show it back
here into the scene um
but you have i assume that everybody
would like worked the script
like ripped it apart and like really
worked on it like i
had like gotten all the subtext and all
the beats of the entire film and like
where your character sort of fits in
thematically for the entire film and how
are you
servicing that and all i just assumed
that and then i realized
that that's not true so that is
something i expect of my actors
i expect them to have worked on the
script pulled it apart
put it back together have their subtext
understand what their character needs in
that scene
what they're not getting in that scene
and if they can't identify that like ask
me like i'll tell you let's work
let's let's get in there because and
then
and then yeah and then you just gotta
relax and do the scene but if you've
done all that work
you don't have to think about it because
it's it's it's planted in there and it's
going to be flying through your
mind without you understanding it
or needing to um without you
understanding that it's happening
you know and it will come through the
performance so yeah
and i need to have a good attitude and a
and a
like a good work ethic and you know
anything less than that to me i'm just
like
i just find unacceptable i just
i just do because here's the thing about
acting it's such a fantastic art form
and your moment in a film production
comes
with the exception of post-production
comes after everything's been set up
people have been working on this for
months years sometimes
you know like you walk onto a set and
and this is true for me like
when i was acting like i didn't know
what had gone into getting that location
i didn't know what had gone into you
know making sure the crew had enough
parking
or you know there was a hassle with with
lunch and they couldn't have it you know
where they planned to have it and they
had to get another place so
that's all just location based how about
getting the money together for the
project
or the script was it in great shape or
did they have to go through all these
rewrites
you know the director did they have to
fight for this getting this role
this um job or not or you know the
cinematographer like how much would they
put into how much thought had they put
into the lighting and
all of the wardrobe everything like you
know maybe there's subtext in the
wardrobe that the you know or the
the um production design you know like
what's like right now what's behind you
like informs
what we gather from you what's behind me
you know i can turn this on if you want
whatever you know gives you information
about me it's all these subtleties right
and as an actor you're walking in when
all that's been set up you're walking
into this party that's
already been planned right
so if you come in and you've got an
attitude or you've got
um you're resistant to doing another
tape or
or you don't know your lines i mean it's
just like
oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding me
so i have obviously high respect for
actors and high respect for that art
form
but to not have that perspective as far
as
what has gone on before you walked on
the set i think is
is it's a shame and it's
damaging to the production and to your
career
because we all talk
hey i work i'm i'm thinking about
working with so-and-so and i saw that
you
you know worked with him on a film you
know what was the experience like
because when you have all that set up
the last thing you want is somebody
coming in like
right when everything's set up you have
nine of the ten pieces and the tenth
piece comes in
and just drops a firecracker in the
middle of the whole thing
um yeah but
i had actors who were you know
they got it they got that they're part
of this collage
you know we're all part of making this
collage and
this is their part this is my part this
you know what i mean
and then you come together and make
something really cool yeah you can feel
it while you're watching the movie
the the one ensemble member i couldn't
believe when i saw him on screen was
zachary gordon because i think one of my
very first uh
junkets i ever covered was his diary of
a wimpy kid movie and he's like
itty bitty and we're in a new york city
movie theater and he's a kid promoting
his movies so to see him like
like a full grown adult now commanding
the screen i was just i was very
pleasantly surprised
he was great you know i had seen with my
kids those other films
but when he came in to audition i didn't
make the connection that he was the
person that had been
in those films i don't know why um
no i just like saw you know the audition
i was like whoa
he's uh this is good this is good he's
really right for this part
and then it was only uh i think before
we did the
the callback or something and i
looked him up and i was like two things
i was like
same as you like oh wait this is the
same guy and then also
[ __ ] kudos to him that his that he
doesn't have representation that said
hey
you know my client's like a huge star
are you kidding me don't you know the
films he's been in
and he every time i watch his
performance and
trust me i've seen this film like you
know i don't know i should have counted
like you know 7500 times or something
um he does these little things in the
scene
said i'm like dude i love it but
sometimes i
you know like in the edit like i didn't
notice until i was you know a little
further in or something
um but yeah he was terrific everybody
really great jobs
the actors you know and there's so and
especially the actors that have the
smallest parts
the authenticity that they bring to
those parts like
like pulls up the value of the film
so much and i just like i so appreciate
that it makes a huge difference
when you have people in smaller parts
that are like whatever maybe you cast a
friend who's not so good or
or you brought in some local talent
that's like yeah that's so great
um it it affects the film it it
if only subliminally the the audience
will like
they'll pull back a little bit because
there's something that's like not
doesn't really fit right with the rest
of the film
no small parts i feel like that's
something that's been coming up in a lot
of interviews recently and i like it
before i have to let you go i do want to
tap into the editing process
just a little and i guess mush it with
the onset experience because
you've got olivia's performance you've
got
justin as uh as the voice that we're
hearing
you've also got the text on the screen
so how much
of that has to be prepared in advance
how much can you convey
to olivia while she's acting on set and
how much of it comes together in the
edit
so i knew i was going to have the
violent imagery because i wanted to
illustrate that you know a lot of people
a lot of
a lot of us will just shrug off the the
sort of uh
critical voice you know and just say
like oh i'm just hard on myself but to
me
like it it creates uh
especially if it's in the same place
over and over again it could be a paper
cup but then it starts feeling like a
furrow so
uh or it becomes a furrow or a scar and
so i wanted that i
already knew i wanted that violent
imagery um i already knew i wanted
you know in the original script like the
voice of course but then as we were
cutting i was like
i need the voice like all the time like
as soon as he lets up from her
then the film's done she's fine so
luckily before i went to record justin's
voice i was like you know
sat down with justin i was like okay
we've got like the script that we've got
and then i've got all these other things
i want you to say he was like let's go
for it
um so that was great and then the
writing
the main goal i mean when you ask like
what did i want this film to be in the
beginning i
always wanted this to be a more
immersive experience for the viewer i
wanted it i didn't want them to like sit
back and watch
you know an actress play violet and kind
of go through this experience
i really wanted the audience to go
through it i
like putting on a coat or getting in a
car i really you know get into a
little boat and go into it's a small
world you know what i mean like go
into this violet this experience
and see where it taps into your own your
own life your own world
and so because of that the writing came
i was like i need to bring i need
i need all these layers i need and and
what it did the writing
with the voice like created this
pressure cooker
on on olivia's performance it it
it really made it for me because it was
like her trying to
like bubble up like you know like as if
she's been buried alive and like you
know
arms coming up through the ground like
somebody somebody get me out of here i
don't want to be here anymore now that
now that i realize how heavy this is
because you can be in a situation not
realize it
and then the day you realize it you can
go you you feel like
oh my god wait a minute how have i been
comfortable with this for so long like
today's the day that i
and you can't undo what you just found
out
about how you're living whether it's in
a relationship or a situation or
whatever
and so that's the writing is out of that
like
like that desperate like oh my god get
me out of here and then the voice being
more
constant just created this sandwich of
so you see that you know then you see
that like olivia and that performance
like just
barely holding it together with that
under that pressure
coming up pressure cooker's a good way
to describe it i just i just watched
like a giant studio movie where i found
myself in the third act like rooting for
a character that was in an
action set piece and i found myself
yelling at the screen in a similar
manner i'm not gonna spoil anything but
towards the end of your movie rooting
for her to make one decision over the
other and it's just
like i stopped dead in my tracks and
kind of compared the two experiences and
it's
you know it's crazy that storytelling on
screen can elicit the same reaction but
in two completely different ways and
no no i was i was very very interested
in that
thank you that's great yeah yeah i love
all those
i i mean for me filmmaking is like i
said earlier like making a collage
and i want all of my films to
to have that sensibility not this same
style as violet like that's violet style
but in other ways like there's so many
things we can do with the medium of film
you know i don't have to just like
shoot master coverage coverage and we're
out of the scene like
there's so many you know i've been
messing around in photoshop for many
many years
and in the same way i can mess around
photoshop i want to mess around and film
and to the extent that it that
it drives that that story home or that
intent or that thesis statement you know
not just for the sake of it that's silly
but whatever methods i can use
to drive home whatever the thesis
statement is of of a film generally and
specifically in those scenes
uh i want to use it so i'm looking
forward to
doing that in many more films i i want
to see it happen
so hurry up and make more movies but in
the meantime i'm going to make sure our
audience
knows about violet do keep an eye out on
it out for it
i mean you could probably already tell
at this point but i highly recommend it
when
it does get its release i'm rooting for
you guys justine congratulations and
thanks for coming by the channel
thanks thanks for having me